oh okay oh
what is this a
a meatball really
[Laughter]
it's always more fun to mess with dwight
with an audience that was usually pam so
now that she's out i had to find someone
else
turns out that stanley is quite the
comedy fan
but not everything makes him laugh
he has very specific tastes
through a painstaking process of trial
and error i found out what he likes
and it's really weird
jim come on so juvenile
what the you've been meatballed
are you ready for some meatball oh man
this is not very clever jim i know look
for your stapler
really jim really
very funny
okay
what's a haul
32 meatballs good
day that idiot's been feeding us for a
week we'll never have to buy meatballs
again
it's a miracle she loves him
i don't know about
love
she loves me
outside my car two minutes
all right something's come up i gotta go
no no no she'll wake up no i have
something to do i know what you have to
do please stay with cece
dwight
i've always considered us to be very
good friends great friends
remember your concussion
i do
but you married my worst enemy well i
think enemy's a strong word cause i
think we have a really charming back and
forth
i will require beer and pizza to think
this over absolutely from jim well i
don't think that's do it
what kind of pizza would you like
surprise me
no
pepperoni
insert it in my mouth okay that's not
gonna make your pizza eating experience
any better trust me oh try me jim
just don't think of it as degrading
think of it as you happen to be moving
the pizza six inches this way and he
happens to be biting it i'd prefer for
him to think of it as degrading okay
crust first
okay
now the
beer hear me jim
gentle
[Music]
we can get him to drive to canada
what the hell is this what are you
trying to cop a feel or something no
dude no dude no dude i was just listen
god i don't even i don't even know how
to explain this um
uh dwight asked me to be in an alliance
and then um
um
we were we've just been messing with him
uh because of the whole alliance thing
um it's just office pranks it's stupid
it's just office pranks and alliance
what the hell's he talking about
i have absolutely no idea
come on
do i feel bad about betraying jim
not at
all
that's the game
convince him we're in an alliance get
some information throw him to the wolves
that's politics baby get what you can
out of someone
then crush them
i think jim might have learned a very
valuable lesson
uh yeah i just got my replacement credit
card
do you want the number oh it's uh four
seven nine three
zero zero three two
three three one three
the security code is
nine two seven okay great thank you very
much bye
so dwight did take the bait
use my credit card numbers to send a 200
bouquet of flowers
to my wife
from me
[Laughter]
boom
hey
jimmy what's up
not much cool
very cool
i bet if you tried you could grow the
best beard of anyone in this office
thanks dwight
that laugh is so infectious creeping me
out i'm gonna go
i didn't mean any of those things i just
said
and you can expect the same thing from
everyone in this office if you don't nip
this whole employee of the month
situation in the bud
make it about the work i guess you think
you should get it
this encompasses all available data
hours tardiness unconfirmed sick days
participation everyone has been assigned
a random number
for total fairness and transparency also
this should be accompanied by a monetary
prize well in an ideal world in an ideal
world i would have all 10 fingers on my
left hand so my right hand could just be
a fist for punching okay if it's all the
same to you i'm just gonna take away
survival skills and self-defense i'm
gonna run this by toby and accounting
and have him assemble the data that's
okay i'll do it
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome i know
you're all very excited but no matter
who gets this i just want to say that
you guys are all employees of the month
of my ass
and the winner is
employee number nine and that is
number nine number nine
jim halbert what what are you kidding
phone no
okay wait
i was not
i did not i get what did not
that was not
how come now guys listen this was
anonymous all right there's no way i
could have given it to myself because i
didn't even know
who was on here i just gave it to the
employee with the highest overall score
to my tally you just won back your own
parking spot a vacation day and a nice
tidy quarter of a thousand dollars from
all of us will everybody just stop for a
second cause obviously i'm not taking
any of it a mistake has been made and
we'll figure it out second of all there
was no cash prize yes
dwight yeah you said in an ideal world
there would be a cash prize isn't that
what you said no dwight i meant yes in a
perfect world someone would get money
but not but
in your perfect world only you get money
yeah
dumb dude i know all right
this is kevin malone is david there
no he's on his weekly staff meeting can
i take a message
tell him i'm mad at jim cause he's
asking us to give money to pam this is
stanley hudson
jim halpert is a menace it's toby
flenderson
listen things are getting really bad
down here
you've reached the voicemail of dwight
kurt schrute please leave
[Music]
i have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but i think it was worth it
um i was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept
throwing him
until he exhausted himself and uh
then
how about icing it lol dwight
hey pickles merry christmas open
immediately
love swiss cheese
damn it
think your affectionate nicknames would
be your undoing did you jim
let that be a lesson to you all
i'm sorry
i had no idea no it's okay
okay oh my god
oh my god no no no no
okay this is it what what is this one go
go oh my gosh
[Music]
ah
in the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all
it's fear
merry christmas
you